the mandalorian is a series that focuses
on dinjarin but it's also pulled in
beloved characters from many different
areas
of the star wars universe here are a few
season 2 characters that mean more than
casual fans might think
star wars has always been a space
western but the mandalorian episode the
marshall
takes it even further here we meet a
gunslinging space martial named kobanth
with the empire fallen and jabba the
hutt taken down tatooine is left with a
bunch of mining syndicates
vying for power someone had to set
things straight after the resistance
took down the empire
so why not a space sheriff though the
episode is fan's first on-screen
appearance in the star wars universe
he originally appeared in chuck wendig's
canon trilogy aftermath
there we learned that vanth is a former
slave and has been protecting freetown
from red key raiders
even though it isn't likely that most
fans of the mandalorian have read the
aftermath trilogy
we still may see more advanced part of
the galaxy in upcoming disney plus
content a straight up space western
might be just what we need in a galaxy
far far away
the mandalorians frog lady may not have
a meta backstory within the star wars
universe
but her struggle speaks volumes about
the state of the galaxy
following the savage rule of the empire
frog lady is on a simple mission to
deliver her eggs back to the moon
trask because this clutch of eggs is the
last of her life cycle
she is desperate to keep the eggs safe
from harm no pressure
and no help from grogo who seemingly
never met a creature he didn't want to
eat
frog lady provides us with a deeply
personal look at the state of
civilization
throughout the galaxy much of the star
wars franchise focuses on massive
battles
without shining much light on the
aftermath of that destruction
how many other species are almost
completely wiped out after the empire's
destruction
not all species eliminations come from
the massive blast of a death star
and frog lady shows us how deep and vast
the herd following war can be
for the beings caught in its wake it's
not often that a jedi leaves the order
but then again ahsoka tano is no
ordinary force wielder
ahsoka first appeared during the 2008
animated film clone wars which spawned a
tv series of the same name
while at soka's final scene in the clone
wars series finale
leaves her journey open-ended viewers do
know anakin skywalker's former padawan
has left her role as a jedi completely
behind
yet as we see in the mandalorian she
doesn't abandon the force
rosario dawson assumed the role of
ahsoka for the mandalorian for the
show's 13th episode
the jedi and when she appears for the
first time ahsoka wields a pair of white
lightsabers
which she purified from dark side
crystals canon projects like clone wars
comic books and novels
have introduced fans to numerous force
wielders and their lightsabers
but ahsoka is a force-sensitive
character who's actively wielding the
force
while rejecting the jedi way her choice
to follow her own rules leaves room for
fascinating storylines
and characters that don't jibe with jedi
beliefs the former jedi left her mark on
the mandalorian by shedding light on the
life of the child when she revealed his
true name and his pastor to padawan at
the jedi academy
that was just the beginning rosario
dawson's ahsoka is getting a very own
self-titled show
on disney plus valenhess may be a new
character for the mandalorian but what
he represents goes far beyond his
character's scope
star wars has a significant number of
villains but most of them are pretty
one-dimensional
we all hate grand moff tarkin the
ruthless imperial naval leader
but beyond a few scenes where he
demonstrates his cunning nature
or talks about military tactics we don't
get a sense of who he is we often don't
know why characters who represent the
empire do the things they do
outside of fear and the lust for power
so it's interesting to hear from some
lower level villains
in chapter 15 the believer mando has to
sneak into an imperial base with former
imperial sharpshooter
mix mayfield and before the pair can
sneak back out
they're cornered by hess he was once
mayfield's superior officer
when mayfield asked hess how he could
sacrifice his entire division to wipe
out a city
hess replies see boys everybody thinks
they want freedom
but what they really want is order
hes toasty empire at which point
mayfield shoots him dead
but before that hess's monologue offers
a rare glimpse into the mindset
of the empire's military commanders and
it's chilling
even though his answer doesn't come as a
surprise given that the mandalorian
focuses on characters who have reasons
for avoiding the new republic
after the fall of the empire it's
unsurprising that we don't see many
former rebels
pilate carson tiva and his wingman
trapper wolf are exceptions
along with others from the rebel ranks
who helps take down the empire the pair
now monitors goings-on in an official
capacity
policing a galaxy healing after decades
of strife mandalorian viewers are
introduced to the duo in chapter 10 the
passenger when mando's attempt to avoid
them nearly gets him eaten by a giant
space spider
it isn't just that he's feeling shy
after teaver and wolf rescue him
we find out there's a warrant out for
his arrest when bando asks teva if he's
going to try and take him into custody
the pilot admits he or two but for
better or worse the new republic is far
from the authoritarian regime that the
empire was
and tiva lets him go this encounter is
more than a glimpse of republic police
work in action
the mandalorian also threw in a fun
easter egg for fans to discover longtime
star wars writer and mandalorian
producer
occasional director dave felloni plays
trapper wolf
and with the upcoming star wars disney
plus series rangers of the new republic
which will take place at during the same
time as the mandalorian and ahsoka
we may see a lot more of these too we
all know boba fett is important but
let's be real he's pretty tame in the
original trilogy
he stumbles over his armor he barely
says a word
and he's accidentally bested by a blind
han solo as far as villains go
star wars has done better but is he
really a villain the original trilogy
made it clear that he was only in it for
the money however given his urge to help
mando and the warriors code of ethics he
shows in the mandalorian
it's hard not to wonder if the empire
forced his hand following his surprise
return and subsequent role in rescuing
grogu from maf gideon
boba fett slater's now clean and he
returns to tatooine to take over jabba
the hutt's palace
we've yet to learn what the former
bounty hunter has been up to all these
years
was he stuck in the digestive track of a
sarlacc for several years
or did he escape relatively quickly
after han launched him into the pit
perhaps his motives aren't as pure as
they might seem
he does save fenix shand noting that
they were both left for dead in the
desert
maybe he was once the villain everyone
believed him to be but he's clearly been
changed
then again the teaser for this disney
plus series the book of boba fett
suggests otherwise he's a little too
smug when he kills bib fortuna and
claims he's thrown what does it take to
stop assassin fenix shan's from killing
people for money
and near-death experience apparently but
better a change of heart later than ever
if fenix shand has actually changed her
tune we briefly learn about the assassin
in season one of the mandalorian
and we discover that she's a mercenary
who's already killed for the hutts
it's not until season two that her
character is more thoroughly fleshed out
fittingly given that shend is named
after the desert dwelling fennec fox the
assassin is sly and the motives are
often unclear
while shand isn't exactly a hero she
does have some kind of code
the mercenary follows boba fett after he
saves her from death
and she even puts her life on the line
to help mando find grogu when moth
gideon's dark troopers kidnap him
both she and boba fett are incredibly
hard to read but
hopefully the book of boba fett will
answer all of our burning questions
star wars fans who haven't tuned in to
the animated series clone wars and
rebels
might not be able to guess by her
appearance in the mandalorian but
bogatan crees is kind of a big deal on
mandalore boca tan is devoted to
returning mandalore to its former glory
and she's taken on the likes of darth
maul to prove it
by the time we see her in the
mandalorian bokeh tan is in pursuit of
the darksaber which is being wielded by
moth gideon
it's a quest that grows more complicated
after mando becomes as rightful owner by
defeating gideon in combat
during the season finale then tries to
give her the weapon but as a delighted
gideon points out the darksaber must be
won
not given it's unclear at the close of
season 2 just how much
mando's ownership of the darksaber will
mean for mandalore and bogatan
but any conflict between the two won't
be the first time they've clashed when
they meet she scoffs at mando's refusal
to take off his helmet
basically accusing him of following a
cult-like faction of mandalorian
tradition
being faced with bokeh tan's assertion
that you can be a mandalorian without
shielding your face from the galaxy
marks the first time mando really
questions his staunch beliefs
the question lingers as we see him
remove his helmet twice after that
conversation
particularly in the poignant closing
moments of the season finale when he
removes it in order to give grosgu a
proper goodbye
disney build the rise of skywalker as a
swung song to the skywalker saga
ray even buries luke and leia's
lightsabers putting their storyline to
rest
it wasn't subtle yet the mandalorian
second season finale
brought her to re-emergence of the
skywalkers in a major way
luke himself saunters onto moff gideon
ship decimating an entire platoon of dog
troopers in his response to grogoo's
call
it's clear from the minute a hooded
figure brandishes a green lightsaber
that luke is under the shroud of mystery
but many fans were still thrilled to see
him remove his hood
looking and sounding just like he did in
return of the jedi while the moment
as one of triumph it also poses the
question just how far will this go
will disney be whipping out cgi luke in
another 30 years
if luke is fair game then who else are
they going to cgi back into existence
with a slew of disney plush shows on the
horizon including obi-wan kenobi and
lando
it's hard not to wonder whether the
skywalker era will ever be over
and while for nostalgia's sake that's a
great comfort it also might prevent
other great stories from emerging the
bottom line disney may have been skewing
the truth when they said the rise of
skywalker
was the end of the skywalker story but
fans still have to admit the scene was
still pretty epic
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite star wars characters are
coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one